we have a new report out uh that seeks
to answer the question
how many coronavirus deaths can we
really attribute to former president
donald trump
and you know one of the things we knew
intuitively during the trump presidency
and which was concerned confirmed a
number of times by different studies
was that no president could have
predicted every coronavirus death no
president could have even
uh prevented rather rather than
predicted predicted is a different thing
no president could have prevented every
coronavirus death uh we were going to
have many deaths as even countries that
dealt with the virus well had
many deaths but the lack of taking the
virus seriously by the trump
administration from day one
certainly was at least partially
responsible for some
of the deaths a new report now says
that 40 of the deaths that took place
in 2020 could have been avoided
if trump had merely handled the virus
well enough for the u.s to have the same
not not number of cases but mortality
rate of other wealthy countries at our
level of development
this study was published in the lancet
one of the uh oldest and best known
medical journals and it explains
that the us had
way more deaths a higher mortality
rate during the pandemic than other
rich countries countries including the
uk
and a number of other countries and that
many of the cases and deaths were
avoidable
they could have been avoided by the
federal government response
being more serious from the beginning
rolling out testing earlier on
having stricter guidelines or at least
making it clear that they should be
enforced and that donald trump wanted to
see those
enforced and unfortunately some of these
problems date back even before
donald trump we know that the united
states when it comes to health care
even though we spend a ton of money on
health care we often have worse outcomes
than many
other wealthy developed countries uh
germany canada
uk so on and so forth and so part of
this
is a bigger problem than donald trump um
a lot of our systems not
interacting well federal and state not
interacting well
so on and so forth but then beyond that
was the failed federal response from
donald trump and i think a lot of us
intuitively
understand this the number of infections
early the lack of
just being realistic the lack of letting
actual medical professionals guide the
response and as i've said before
if indeed donald and we'll talk about
this in a moment when we talk about joe
biden's approval rating
if donald trump had simply said what do
doctors think we should do
what do public health experts think we
should do epidemiologists
immunologists people who know about this
and aren't going to say things like
would the flu vaccine work against
coronavirus as donald trump did back in
i don't remember if it was february or
march
many of these deaths would have been
avoided and we now know that
beyond any doubt whatsoever and
the question now becomes under new
leadership
can we do as well as other countries
when it comes to vaccine distribution
and lowering the mortality rate and
keeping cases
low if and when we get them low so far
the numbers are
cautiously optimistic we had a couple
days in the last week
where there were two million
vaccinations done each day
if indeed we have a third vaccine
approved sometime in the near future as
it looks like we will
it's not completely unreasonable to
think that we could get to a steady 2 or
2.5 million vaccine doses per day
and uh we the these are not you know one
of the
the saddest things that has taken place
during the pandemic
obviously the deaths and cases and
economic implications and
psychological impact for so many people
have been terrible
but one of the saddest things that that
we've also seen
uh has been the realization that the
people in charge really do make a
difference
what the politics are of your governor
in dealing with the pandemic it really
makes a difference
whether there is a competent federal
government response really makes a
difference
when you have people like jared kushner
saying well the stockpile
is our stockpile it's not for the states
that's just not a disgusting political
statement that you see on tv
that has a real trickle-down impact and
hopefully we're going to see that
improve
and it seems as though the american
people are confident that it is
improving uh joe biden with the highest
initial approval rating
in 28 years let's talk about that now
one of our sponsors today is lucy and
they are giving my audience
20 off lucy is a company founded by
caltech scientists with only one mission
which is to help people quit smoking
and vaping by offering a clean
affordable
nicotine alternative now many of you
know you've heard the stories
i've known several people in my life who
have struggled with quitting smoking
i've seen how difficult it can be and
nicotine alternatives can be hugely
helpful
lucy offers a nicotine gum in three
flavors wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate they also have
lozenges which come in cherry ice
flavor lucy is affordable it'll ship
right to your door you don't have to go
out to the store
shipping is always free you can buy
single boxes or save with a subscription
it's time to throw the cigarettes away
and get rid of the vape
and lucy can make it easier you'll find
a ton of excellent reviews online from
countless people
who have used lucy to quit smoking and
vaping
go check them out at lucy.co i've put
the link right underneath this video and
you'll get 20 percent off when you use
the coupon code
pacman and just a quick disclaimer i'm
required to give
these products contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical